[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu den richtigen
fragen hierbei bild ja es corona
endgültig vorbei seitdem der krieg da
ist das fragen wir jetzt den
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach bei uns im studio dank auch
ihrer fragen zu hause ihrer zuschauer
fragen und ich fange gleich mal an mit
dem kommentar herr lauterbach von yvonne
müller die schreibt uns liebe bild ich
bin so wahnsinnig wütend auf euch auf
uns in dem fall man findet überhaupt
keine schlagzeilen mehr zum corona waren
sind nur noch ukraine also ist nicht so
sie stellen sich heute der korona
sprechstunde hierbei gilt aber natürlich
gibt's ein spannungsverhältnis zwischen
diesen beiden themen erst recht wenn wir
die bilder aus mario pohl derzeit sehen
aus dieser völlig zerbombten völlig
zerstörten stadt in der ost ukraine das
den tonaufnahmen von dort erlaubt wenn
wir solche bilder jetzt jede stunde
immer wieder aufs neue im fernsehen
sehen die brutalität dieses krieges
sehen dieses putin angriffskrieges
können sie verstehen dass der eine oder
andere millionen möglicherweise in
deutschland sagen angesichts solcher
bilder angesichts dieses krieges corona
ist eigentlich nichts mehr was mir angst
macht
das darf man nicht gegeneinander
ausspielen und zunächst mal möchte ich
sagen dass dieser brutale
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg von putin
die berichterstattung verdient
diese bekommt das ist der bekommt also
das ist tatsächlich also etwas das die
menschen sehen müssen und
was auch medial genau in der offenheit
aufgearbeitet werden muss wir jetzt
sehen das ist schlicht und ergreifend
eine katastrophe die sich in zeitlupe
vor unseren augen abwickelt und ist
es man kann es nicht beschreiben das
wären ja auch krankenhäuser zerstört es
werden kinder also einrichtungen
zerstört es gibt keine praxis mehr die
noch funktioniert die menschen
versteckten sich dieses grauen muss
dargestellt werden daran können wir
nicht vorbei geht dass das medial so
aufgearbeitet wird wie jetzt das
verstehe ich und daher ist die
berichterstattung mit diesem schwerpunkt
das geht wollen völlig klar dass das was
auch in unseren köpfen macht man kann
sich ja nicht um 10 krisen gleichzeitig
kümmern und vor der sie in sachen
gleichzeitig angst haben selbst die
renommiertesten psychologen sagen an der
stelle eigentlich kann der mensch sich
nur auf eine angst gleichzeitig
konzentrieren das heißt man blendet
jetzt krone aus coruna ist vorbei in dem
moment ja es wird zum teil nicht mehr so
viel berichtet das kann ich auch
verstehen und bei coma ist es ja nicht
nur dass man mit der angst halte hier
arbeiten
darauf dass er sich sogar für falsch
sondern wir müssen
aufklären und wir müssen warnen dort wo
angemessen und wir müssen versuchen
regeln zu schaffen die funktionieren und
wir müssen versuchen hilfe zu geben das
ist ja auch andere gründe weshalb ich
heute mich wieder den fragen der
zuschauer stellen weil sie halt beste
falsch mit angst zu arbeiten das nicht
falsch mit angst aber das wird mir ja
ständig unterstellt dass noch mehr
häufigste zuschauerfragen ja genau und
das ist ja auch etwas was also von also
ihrem blatt und auch also von ihren
kollegen wir oft also unterstellt wird
aber ich arbeite schlicht nicht mit
angst mache
das muss man klar sagen das ist ein
unterschied ob ich mit angst arbeiter-
oder ob ich mit einer realistischen
einschätzung dessen was passiert also
arbeite ich bin ein beispiel wenn sich
hier ist ein ungeimpfter infiziert und
denkt omikron also 70 jahre alt ist für
mich nicht so gefährlich eine milde
variante dann würde ich erklären das ist
nicht so er hat dann doch ein
erhebliches risiko dass ins krankenhaus
muss da ist er vielleicht schwerer
erkrankt dass er möglicherweise
verstirbt und dass er möglicherweise
werden das überlebt bleiben ich sehe
eine warnung
und da würde gar keine zweifel genau so
ist es wenn man wenn man in der
vergangenheit mit prognosen gearbeitet
hat die weit über das hinaus geschossen
sind was anschließend ein getreuer
eingetreten ist das ist das was
zuschauer immer wieder kritisieren auch
im vorfeld dieser sendung sagen halt na
ja daran sieht man ja der arbeitet eilt
mit angst der macht der ist ein panik
minister aber wenn man erst erstens also
die prognosen die ich gemacht habe ich
habe selbst ganz wenige modellierungen
gemacht und die waren über das noch
nicht mal so schlecht wie vor wichtig
aber ich beziehe mich meistens auf
modellierungen anderer spezialisten
beispielsweise eine modellierung von kai
nagel oder eine modellierung des robert
koch instituts und wenn diese
modellierung dann also die realität die
später eintritt nicht so komplett
bezahlt weil auch zum teil unsere
maßnahmen gewirkt habe dann ist das
keine angst mache sondern ich habe mit
auf der grundlage der besten
vorliegenden wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse habe ich eine prognose
vorgestellt aber das ist doch keine
angst mache wenn die prognose dann nach
ostagar lauterbach lassen jetzt einmal
sind jetzt kurz weg gekommen von dem
einen punkt die eine angst und die
andere angst ist das was was sie
möglicherweise auch an sich selber
feststellen sie werden krieg schauen
auch vermutlich jeden tag werden sich
genau diese bilder die wir gerade
gezeigt haben auch ständig anschauen
auch im kabinett ist das natürlich thema
sie sind selbst mindestens ja mehr als
am rande betroffen in ihrem ressort von
diesem krieg zum beispiel über die
flüchtlingslager dort das heißt stellen
sie das bei sich selber auch fest eine
verschiebung des interesses der
aufmerksamkeit weg von corinna hein
afghan zahl also ich bin ja für die
groner bekämpfung zuständig und wenn ich
sehr unaufmerksam würde und würde mich
anderen themen zu stark widmen das wäre
nicht akzeptabel meine aufgabe ist es
mir endlich verteidigungsminister ich
bin nicht die innenminister sondern also
ich bin der gesundheitsminister ich muss
dafür sorgen dass alles was mit diesem
krieg zu tun hat und was gesundheit
betrifft so weit wir das regeln können
gut funktioniert also gott zum beispiel
bekommen die flüchtenden die hier nach
deutschland kommt bekommen die die
medikamente oder sie versorgen die sie
brauchen sofort sind wir in der lage
hilfsmittel medizinisches mittwoch
betäubungsmittel narkosemittels in die
also gebiete zu bringen wo die menschen
das brauchen wir zu mensch zum teil also
wird dort sind schmerzmittel knapp
narkosemitteln betäubungsmittel knapp
das muss rein mario pohl ist alles
klappt alles was er noch ein dritter
bürgermeister sagt gerade bei uns in der
sendung wir leben hier wie im
mittelalter nach neuss aber wir müssen
die medizinischen hilfsgüter die müssen
wir als land bringen das ist etwas woran
nicht mitarbeiter wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die erste aus deutschland
die helfen wollen dass sie das auch
können entweder in der ukraine oder in
polen in den anrainerländern dass sie
dort helfen können und schließlich wir
fangen auch jetzt an
menschen die in der ukraine verletzt
worden sind oder verwundet worden sind
in deutschland zu versorgen wenn die
ausgeflogen werden zuerst aus der ost
ukraine in die westukraine und dann nach
polen dann werden die über so ein system
verteilt das kleeblatt system was vorbei
den kopfball nämlich schon genutzt haben
da bin ich auch mit zuständig aber das
sind die dinge wo ich mich konzentrieren
zivilisten oder auch soldaten also
darüber möchte ich hier nicht auf
vortragen auf jeden fall wir helfen wo
wir können es werden menschen
ausgeflogen das system beginnt hier
nicht in dem ausmaß sind dass jetzt die
ersten oder her genau dass er die ersten
die ersten also das system muss ja erst
mal funktionieren muss wird dann
getestet
also diese ersten tests haben
stattgefunden das wird jetzt mehr werden
und also das heißt es gibt schon
ukrainische verwundete das lassen wir
mal
die hier versorgt er genau die er
versorgt werden also wir haben das jetzt
also vor ein paar tagen erstmal nix los
gezogen das ist die ganze kette
funktioniert also auch so kann der west
ukraine polen mann aus polen nach
deutschland verteilt über ein
gemeinsames also lagezentrum von also
bund und ländern und dass dieses
kleeblatt systems also was wir auch bei
der pandemie gehabt haben bei den comic
patienten somit als somit diese vier
bereiche da bin ich auch mit zuständig
längst nicht allein da sind die anderen
ministerien innenminister im
außenministerium der schwerst verletzte
sind das intensiv lass uns das noch mal
so stehen betreuen lasst uns zum
beispiel das sind leute die eine sehr
also intensive versorgung benötigen und
die also in also intensiv medizinische
einrichtungen also verteilt werden
müssen und das läuft jetzt an das
wichtig deutschland liefert nicht nur
waffen warum ist das so geheim ganz kurz
ohne da in die privatsphäre der menschen
einzugreifen muss jetzt mal gar nicht
aber warum dann also gar wird auch im
märz wird darüber wird auch mehr
berichtet werden aber jetzt läuft er
hier ist erst mal an meine art damit so
etwas umzugehen ist die lassen sie uns
darüber sprechen wenn es wirklich eine
größenordnung also
erreicht hat die es auch wert ist wir
bereiten das jetzt werden das gut
vorbereitet die finanzierung steht dass
er schlicht noch nicht schmücken mit
einem mit der vergleichsweise klein ja
genau das ist also was ich hasse ist
sozusagen das leute sich mücken mit
etwas was angekündigt ist aber noch
nicht läuft ich will es wirklich also
wir werden darüber zu sprechen ich werde
empfang am morgen beispielsweise werden
was volle pulle schon läuft stell das
paket ist die eu komme ich sagen für
gesundheit die wird morgen mein gast an
da gehen wir nach tegel also in das
dortige flüchtlingszentrum jetzt impfen
so gut organisiert hat den impfstoff so
gut besonders also aus meiner sich jetzt
in den letzten monaten eine vorzügliche
arbeit gemacht und arbeite gerne mit ihr
zusammen sie ist also hoch engagiert bei
der also corona bekämpfung und auch bei
der vorbereitung der und mit ihr arbeite
ich eng zusammen sie ist mein gast unser
gast der wir werden also in tegel seien
werden wir also die sache somit
ankündigen was schon läuft nicht
ankündigen was in planung ist okay da
müssen wir sie dann später daran herr
minister remmel wir diese frage haben
wir im vorfeld dieser sendung gestellt
groß auch auf bild.de wer hört in dieser
corona pandemie eigentlich noch auf sie
unsere zuschauer haben dann ganz eigene
meinung was ist ihre antwort auf diese
frage wer hört noch auf sie ich glaube
es noch viele auf mich dahingehend und
ich bin es ja nicht allein auf die
wissenschaftler auch hören die im
expertenrat die bundesregierung somit
auch mich beraten diejenigen die noch
maske tragen diejenigen die noch
vorsichtig sein die sind diejenigen die
nach einer infektion die quarantäne und
isolations regeln beachten das sind
nicht wenige es ist richtig dass also
hier
leider muss man sagen in der
berichterstattung also eine der eindruck
entstanden ist dass omikron eine sehr
milde variante ist und der andruck ist
nicht ganz richtig für diejenigen die
ungeimpft sind oder diejenigen die
risikofaktoren haben ist das halt nicht
der fall wir haben nach wie vor ein
erhebliches risiko daher habe man jeden
tag also zwischen 200 und 300 menschen
das ist so viel wie damals kommen wir
gleich noch mal darauf zu sprechen auf
die zahlen auch auf die sterblichkeit
werden gleichzeitig eine wahnsinnig hohe
dunkelziffer das haben sie gerade am 4
nochmal gemeinsam mit lothar wieler auch
festgestellt dass heißt wir wissen
eigentlich relativ wenig über die
tatsächlich hospitalisierung die
tatsächliche sterblichkeit dass sie
jetzt einmal einsteigen etwas tiefer mit
einem fotovergleich aktuell auf
politischer bühne olaf scholz dort
unterwegs einmal im bundestag und einmal
in brüssel unterwegs im europäischen rat
und sie sehen einmal klar so kann man es
in deutschland so sind wir alle im
moment bei der arbeit unterwegs und dann
in brüssel sieht halt einfach rechts
sehen sie es anders aus da wird sich
locker die hand gegeben da wird
gescherzt da wird ohne maske rumgelaufen
also derselbe kanzler unterschiedlicher
ort wie konsequent ist es die länder
haben unterschiedliche regeln und die
unterschiedlichen regeln also müssen
beachtet werden deutschland hat
verhältnismäßig strenge regeln immer
gehabt ja durch die gesamte partie nie
dafür ein teil dieser regeln zeichne ich
selbst auch verantwortlich selbst in der
zeit als ich noch gar nicht minister war
ja vielleicht noch mehr in der zeit
sogar damals auf jeden fall auch und ich
finde das waren keine schlechten regeln
das hat dazu geführt dass wir in
deutschland gegeben wie alt unsere
bevölkerung ist das nicht absurd aber
saßen nämlich trotzdem fragen
beantworten sonst sonst völlig den faden
und kann nicht mehr als schade das wäre
doch schade was nämlich den punkt sagen
also die verhältnismäßig strengen regeln
die biergarten die haben uns auch gut
gedient wir haben vergleich zu anderen
ländern mit einer ähnlichen
altersstruktur haben wir eine deutlich
bessere sterblichkeit und das ist
gelungen obwohl wir eine geringe im boot
haben somit werden zwei handicaps das
ein handicap alte bevölkerung das zweite
handicap viele risiko leute im älteren
semester insbesondere die sich nicht
haben eben verlassen dass wir dann
trotzdem die geringe sterblichkeit hat
ist nur den strengen regeln zu verdanken
sonst wäre das nicht darstellbar wie
viel höher ist jetzt für den kanzler die
gefahr in brüssel
als im bundestag weil
die inzidenz also in belgien ist ja
moment niedriger als beim als bei uns
von da aber ich möchte das nicht also
die die lage ist doch klar die regeln
sind hier andere sind strengere regeln
unsere regeln sind aus meiner sicht
richtig der bundeskanzler hält sich an
die regeln die vor ort notwendig sind
und üblich sind und daher hat er alles
richtig gemacht in der nächste woche am
nächsten samstag ist sozusagen unser
kleiner unser mini freedom day ist es so
ich hoffe nicht das würde ja bedeuten
dass die maßnahmen dann alle auslaufen
bis auf in den in den einrichtungen für
besonders gefährdete gruppen also
meinetwegen pflegeeinrichtungen kranken
also ich glaube dass wir bei der
inzidenz die wir derzeit haben die
hotspot regelungen die ich mit
justizminister buschmann gemacht habe
dass also die länder die benutzten
werden wie jetzt in mecklenburg
vorpommern also geplant auch in hamburg
ich hoffe dass auch andere länder
nachziehen und hierzu also regeln kommen
die gerade in den städten und land
teilen wo wir sehr hohe inzidenz haben
nur noch hohe sterblichkeit haben die
die regeln so nutzen dass da mehr schutz
möglich ist als wenn man auf die region
verzichtet und einfach also so tut als
wenn die pandemie vorbei versetzt
besagte erstmals läuft alles auf das ist
richtig aber es läuft nicht aus wenn die
landtage beschließen neue regeln sich zu
geben enorm das gesetz mitgemacht das
besagt es läuft alles aus genau wo außer
in den hotspots
jetzt werben sie dafür dass es ganz
große hotspots gibt das ganze länder
sich zu hotspots erklären so heißt auch
das angeleitete sagen sie ich bin dafür
ich unterschreibe das gesetz ich
betreibe dieses gesetz um es tatsächlich
gesetz werden zu lassen das alles
ausläuft ich möchte auf der einen seite
das alles ausläuft und auf der anderen
seite möchte ich das fast ganz
deutschland doch dann eben wieder keine
auslaufende maßnahmen haben ja das ist
ja kein widerspruch sondern das hat ja
einfach direkt nein überhaupt nicht das
ist kein widerspruch dass hatte einfach
eine rechtliche komponente der
rechtliche hintergrund ist der der
justizminister in qua amt hat auf der
grundlage also der bewertung der
situation gesagt eine deutschlandweite
gefährdung der gesundheitsversorgung ist
nicht mehr gegeben
daher sind deutschlandweit
einschränkungen rechtlich nicht mehr
machbar wenn sie mir dann nennen sie mir
eine region oder ein großes bundesland
bei dem sie im moment sagen würden da
bin ich froh dass alle maßnahmen
auslaufen
das ist doch ob ich vor bin ich hab
sogar hat gesagt rechtlich geht es gar
nicht anders also sage ich mal ganz gut
wenn du hast das jeder kapiert rechtlich
wäre es nicht möglich gewesen egal wer
verhandelt hätte
deutschlandweite regeln auf rechts
warten weil es eine deutschlandweite
gefährdung nicht mehr aber es wirkt
inkonsistent und es wirkt unehrlich sie
unterschreiben erst in der ampel
regierung das gesetz mit das sagt aller
maßnahmen laufen aus und dann
anschließend kommen sie daher und sagen
ich wünsche mir eigentlich dass ganz
deutschland ein hotspot ist das habe ich
ja nie gesagt ist es das ist eine
unterstellung und zum zweiten hier geht
es nicht um münchen sondern hier geht es
ja um also was ist möglich es war auf
der grundlage der rechtlichen analyse
vom justizminister nicht möglich
bundeseinheitliche regeln zum beispiel
masken pflicht in ganz deutschland zu
beschließen es war einfach rechtlich
möglich ob ich das jetzt wünsche oder
nicht oder ob buschmann das wird ja
sagen wir buschmann hätte gesagt ich
will jetzt die masken fisch in ganz
deutschland hätte es auch nicht machen
können denn auf der ganz gut sind
vergänglich den faden kommen ich mir das
selbst buschmann wer nicht in der lage
gewesen wenn das justizminister nicht in
der lage gewesen jetzt zu sagen masken
sich in ganz deutschland war auf der
grundlage seiner eigenen juristischen
analyse sind solche einschränkungen nur
noch möglich deutschlandweit nicht in
hotspots wenn es eine deutschlandweite
gefährdung gibt aber sie haben ja gerade
gesagt das sei eine unterstellung dass
sie jetzt nicht wollten dass ganz
deutschland ein hotspot wäre das heißt
wo ist aus ihrer sicht im moment möglich
dass alle maßnahmen fallen also dass
tatsächlich das passiert was in ihrem
gesetz steht mein wunsch ist natürlich
mein wunsch ist und war natürlich dass
zum beispiel die masken pflicht in ganz
deutschland gilt das ist ja klar und das
war auch mein wunsch während der
verhandlungen also auch jetzt würde ich
werde das rechtlich ging die masken
pflicht für ganz norddeutschland wollen
natürlich und kein epidemiologe wird es
anders wollen und auch im expertenrat
werden wahrscheinlich alle der meinung
dass die masken pflicht in ganz
deutschland jetzt sinnvoll wäre aber das
ist doch gar nicht die frage sondern die
frage ist ob es dafür noch eine
rechtliche grundlage gibt und da war die
antwort des justizministers ist nicht
mehr da wo kann aus ihrer sicht im
moment auf die hotspot regelung in
deutschland verzieht werden verzichtet
werden kann überall dort wo die
gesundheitliche versorgung muss
verzichtet werden dort wo die
gesundheitliche versorgung nicht
gefährdet ist aber sie können keine
region nennen sie sagen jetzt sein weil
sie vielen ja auch die region nennen das
haben sie auch öffentlich getan wo sie
wollen dass die hotspot regelung im
moment greift ja aber leute in meck-pomm
ist ich werde am montag also die
gesundheitsminister der länder also
quasi in
einer gesundheitsministerkonferenz
darüber informieren was aus meiner sicht
die kriterien sind nach denen also
bundesländer die hotspots bestimmen
können und die kriterien sind eigentlich
ganz einfach zu nennen ist in einer
region oder in einer stadt oder
vielleicht am ganzen bundesland die also
im
versorgung im krankenhaus so gefährdet
das zum beispiel planbare eingriffe im
moment nicht gemacht werden weil zu viel
personal ausgefallen ist oder zu viele
kurven patienten im krankenhaus in das
ist das erste das zweite ist die
notfallversorgung durch diese
krankenhäuser kann nicht mehr
dargestellt werden das dritte ist also
wenn in der pflege werden unter grenzen
die wir quantitativ festhalten die
werden unterschritten und das vierte ist
die krankenhäuser müssen patienten die
schon da sind in andere krankenhäuser
verlegen was sie nicht mehr versorgen
können mit diesen vier kriterien wären
die länder in der lage die hotspot
regelungen umzusetzen darüber werden wir
sprechen und ich appelliere einfach an
die länder jetzt ich weiß dass das
gesetz kompliziert ist ich weiß dass das
nicht schön ist wenn die landtage das
beschließen müssen aber es ging ja nicht
an also ich bitte die länder ist jetzt
zu machen trotzdem ist zu nutzen die
länder werden mit dem gleichen problem
konfrontiert also jetzt zum beispiel
schlägt
gesundheitspolitik aus bayern da steckt
vor lasst uns doch die masken pflicht in
ganz deutschland genau gesagt und dann
ist es eben so der ministerpräsident
sind total ag ja aber ist ja gar also
aber ob er das vorschlägt oder nicht das
ist vollkommen unerheblich es geht
rechtlich nicht das ist der ba das
problem ist dass das ja wie ein trick
von lauterbach bei den mensch dann kommt
doch ihre ladung stellt sich hin in
berlin und sagt mit den grünen und mit
der fdp dann fallen am nächsten samstag
alle maßnahmen und derselbe minister
derselbe gesundheitsminister setzt sich
anschließend hin und sagt ich werbe aber
dafür zumindest in etlichen
bundesländern dass dieselben maßnahmen
eben nicht fallen das kommt bei den
menschen wie ein trick ja gut also dass
kommt also als erstes also ich habe
einiges also
hier vorzutragen aber ich habe keine
tricks nötig das ist nicht mal eine art
das ist also die unterstellungen die
saat ich lese dass manchmal höre dass
und so weiter sondern damit beschäftigt
nicht mal wie es ankommt weil die frage
ist doch wenn ihnen jemand sagt herr
lauterbach ich streiche dass das gilt ab
samstag nicht mehr und dann kommt ihr
ministerkollege und sagt das geht doch
noch es hat nur jetzt jemand anders
beschlossen ist es natürlich für den
betroffenen bürger am ende wurst ja es
bleibt beim selben recht es bleibt bei
denselben maßnahmen ist hat nur jemand
anders beschlossen nee das ist nicht der
unterschied wäre es beschlossen hat und
dann der unterschied ist die
rechtsgrundlage
anders ausgedrückt erstmalig habe dafür
gesorgt dass wir bis zum zweiten vierten
überhaupt einen übergang haben sonst
hätte es schon den freedom day sofort
gegeben es wäre ja fast gar nicht mehr
zu einer einigung gekommen wir haben ja
bis zur letzten stunde verhandelt ja so
dass es überhaupt noch einen übergang
gab wenn die tatsache dass wir jetzt
überhaupt dann übergangen haben bei
dieser riesigen fallzahl ist ja muss man
ja ganz offen es ist ja buschmann und
mehr zu verdanken die praxis nicht
ansatz und zum zweiten ich muss immer
nur sagen
wenn die rechtsgrundlage für
einschränkungen deutschlandweit nicht
mehr gilt kann sie nur noch lokal gelten
und werden sie lokal aber also somit
haben wir jetzt die situation bundesrat
geht es nicht mehr lokal gegner ist und
viele der länder schmollen und mache
noch wahlkampf ich sagen der bund hat
uns im stich gelassen hat nur lokal
klingt ja als wäre jetzt ein teil von
berlin oder wie der westteil von
paderborn betroffen aber die wahrheit
ist ja dann das ganz mecklenburg
vorpommern trotz der heißt oder ganz
bayern dazu eine frage die es nochmal
runterbrechen dieses problem ja
einerseits fällt die masken fläche in
den supermärkten auf der anderen seite
haben sie sofort gesagt sie werben dafür
dass die supermärkte das durch ihr
hausrecht einfach umsetzen unserer
zuschauer harald bands aus heimsheim
fragt er lauterbach warum schieben sie
ihre verantwortung und damit den
schwarzen peter jetzt den supermärkten
zu die mit ihrem haus rechten masken
pflicht durchsetzen sollen den gesetzes
pflicht sie mit der regierungskoalition
nicht festlegen konnten also sie kriegen
das nicht geregelt und jetzt schieben
sie den schwarzen peter so sagt er dass
den supermärkten rewe zum beispiel sie
aber du bist doch immer die gleiche
antwort die rechtliche grundlage für
mich das zu machen ist nicht da sonst
hätte ich das gemacht ich hätte so zu
sagen wenn die rechtliche grundlage da
gewesen wäre hätten wir die masken
pflicht nicht verloren sie wäre ja sagen
ganz deutschland die richtig aber ich
hatte keine rechtliche grundlage
die masken pflicht in ganz deutschland
durchzusetzen
aber die gesundheitliche gefährdung in
ganz deutschland dafür nicht mehr da ist
wenn jetzt ein supermarkt auch auf meine
empfehlung vom hausrecht gebrauch macht
dann ist die rechtliche grundlage dafür
da bei einer sache für die es keine
rechtliche grundlage mehr gibt weil die
gesundheitliche gefährdung nicht mehr
ausrichten gegeben ja bei dieser frage
hat rewe mehr macht als der
bundesgesundheitsministerin das
sogenannte haus recht nutzen kann und
der gesundheitsminister an dass solche
masken pflicht nur beschliessen könnte
wenn es ganz deutschland so ginge dass
wir eine gefährdung der gesundheitlichen
versorgung gefährden befürchten müssen
könnte es sein dass wenn die frage nicht
so wichtig ist dass sie's regel dürfen
sondern nur revis regeln darf dass die
frage dann vielleicht gar nicht so
wichtig ist und man einfach die maske im
supermarkt nicht mehr tragen müssen also
ich kann es ja nur empfehlen ich hätte
auf jeden fall wenn die rechtliche
grundlage dafür da gewesen wäre die
masken pflicht war das ein verfahren ist
wo ich mit geringem aufwand viel
erreichen hätte ich das fortgeführt und
jetzt kann ich einfach nur appellieren
an die länder in den hotspots das zu
machen und ich freue mich auch wenn das
also supermärkte machen das ist gar
keine frage reagiert eigentlich haben
wir haben edeka rewe penny aldi lidl und
so weiter haben die alle gesagt ich
hab's ja wo reiter in der
bundespressekonferenz gesagt ja wie also
ich werde am montag die reaktionen
bekommen und kann ihnen dann gerne
berichten ich kann es zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht aber tatsächlich
ist das eine grundlage ist wie gesagt
david mir ist wichtig in der heutigen
zeit wird ja oft gearbeitet mit
narrativen es werden geschichten erzählt
dass und das ist daher gelungen da hat
sich der durchgesetzt und so weiter und
so fort in der politik heißt mehr lernen
heißt siegen also genau
märchenstunden und so weiter und so fort
wichtig ist dass man bei diesen dingen
auch die fakten beachtet und fakt war
hier die grundlage des
infektionsschutzgesetzes in seiner
reform war die dass wir nicht mehr das
bund für die nicht wollen haben gruppen
einschränkungen beschließen konnten das
ist im wesentlichen auch übrigens eine
rechtslage gegen die ungeimpften ich
habe diese rechtslage nicht geschaffen
und ich habe ihm schon gesagt wenn es
eine andere gelbe wert sogar froh
gewesen aber die grundlage ist die wir
machen nicht mehr viel um die
ungeimpften zu schützen noch einmal zu
rewe zu aldi penny sollen die das nur
den hotspot hotspots durchsetzen ihr
hausrecht die massen pflicht umzusetzen
oder soll das in ganz deutschland das
habe ich doch gerade schon gesagt ich
hätte mich gefreut und hielt es für
sinnvoll wenn wir eine maske pflicht in
ganz neuer art in deutschland ich habe
ja also wird nur dass wir das muss ja
gut ich muss das noch mal wiederholen so
dass du das zuschauer gut kapieren und
so hat uns wenn die rechtliche grundlage
dafür da gewesen wäre das hätte hätten
wir an der masken pflicht für ganz
deutschland bald nur dass die dass jeder
versteht also aus epidemiologischer
sicht wäre die maske nicht für ganz
deutschland sinnvoll gewesen sie ging
aber nicht weil die rechtliche grundlage
ich frage nur deswegen nach weil das ja
kompliziert werden können halten im
landstrich in dem man kaum noch infekt
aalen hat das machen der marktleiter von
penny daher gehen muss und muss sagen
sie mir das ja einen neukölln oder
kreuzberg
das komplizierter ist auch nicht wenn du
jetzt haben sich aktuellen überblick wo
eigentlich am nächsten samstag die
freiheiten die korona maßnahmen komplett
fallen das kann niemand haben wir den
die beschlüsse fallen ja in dieser jetzt
kommenden woche können sie es im moment
über den daumen pein betrifft das die
hälfte deutschland die länder die länder
also haben sich noch nicht deklariert
ich hoffe dass die länder aus einer
viele länder warten ab was passiert ist
in den nächsten tag was machen andere
länder viele länder beobachten sich
viele länder im wahlkampf sogar die sehr
viel parteipolitik damit gemacht ich
will das alles schade ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir doch mein appell an
die gesundheitsministerkonferenz morgen
sein dass wir hingehen und sagen schaut
auf diese vier kriterien überlastung der
krankenhäuser dort wo das der fall ist
sagen wir das denn trotz sie machen das
einheitlich möglichst einheitlich dann
kommen wir gut voran eine frage von
unserem zuschauer nils renschler der
sucht den zeitpunkt wann sagt der
lauterbach eigentlich und damit meint er
ja kein datum sondern der meisten
zeitpunkt wann die pandemie tatsächlich
für sie vorbei ist wir hören von ihnen
immer wieder die pandemie ist nicht
vorbei wann ist für sie also der
zeitpunkt gekommen wo genau das passiert
was muss dafür die voraussetzung seien
laut die pandemie ist ja weltweit ist
geschehen und wie wird auf absehbare
zeit nicht ändern bringt ein beispiel ja
wir sind großes problem entschieden hat
der
mittlere teil von china ist
weitestgehend umkämpft und wo geimpft
mit dem stoff in den ich wirklich gut
wirken es besteht aber zu befürchten
dass in china eine riesige welle
losbricht also weil dort also diese hoch
ansteckenden varianten nicht wirklich
abwendbar sind dass ich dann da neue
varianten entwickeln ist sehr
wahrscheinlich auch in afrika da haben
wir wahrscheinlich irgendwie 15 prozent
geben die bisher dort also können sich
auch jederzeit neue varianten entwickeln
auch in europa ist jetzt sind die
fallzahlen sehr hoch in england steigen
die fallzahlen
also deutlich an dass hier könnten sich
neue varianten entwickeln omikron die
omikron ist derzeit sagen wir sehr
ansteckend haben nicht ganz so
gefährlich gefährlicher als viele leute
denken gerade ältere aber nicht ganz so
gefährlich aber das sind nur wenige
mutationen die dafür sorgen dass auch
mitkommen nicht ganz so gefährlich ist
die dafür sorgen dass das in diese ganz
tief in die lungen abschnitte nicht
eindringt wenn in mutationen also dann
eine variante entscheiden steht omikron
die eu also diese besonders tiefe lungen
abschnitte auch über die besonders tief
in die lungen habt auch betroffen sein
würde haben wir ganz andere lage somit
jemand der jetzt
spekuliert wann ist die plane mich vor
beieinander es ging ja nicht eben um ein
datum das kann man ja ganz klar sagen
also in dem moment wo weiß sie nicht das
virus sich nicht mehr weiter gefährlich
entwickelt oder war es ist derzeit platz
nahm und es war sehr hoch interessante
frage genau das sind hoch interessante
frage die wissenschaftlich der es halt
nicht zu beantworten dass ich bin ja mit
vielen wissenschaftlern im engen
austausch die sich mit der weiteren
entwicklung der pandemie sehr intensiv
beschäftigen und also dass ich ein
privileg was ich habe dass ich sozusagen
als minister aber auch quasi als
wissenschaftler kann ich wirklich mit
den klügsten und also am besten
qualifizierten corona wissenschaftlern
weltweit im gespräch seien nur das tue
ich auch in der tat und da ist keiner
der sich jetzt festlegt viele es gibt
kein pandemie exit es gibt zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt kein klares pandemie exit weil
wir nicht genau wissen wer welche
varianten komme das hoch
sind zum beispiel varianten denkbar
gegen die die jetzigen impfung nicht
wirken dann müssen wir zu neuen impfung
kommen somit also ein pandemie exit kann
man nicht wirklich vorhersagen ich kann
sagen was im herbst kommt also im herbst
werden wir entweder mit nikon oder mit
omikron abkömmlingen oder also mit also
varianten des ersten serie typs der im
wesentlichen aus der welt da also linie
kommt so zu tun haben und werden auf
jeden fall wenn wir die impflücken nicht
schließen durch die endlich werden wir
im herbst wieder mit sanktionen arbeiten
das ist ja das was christian drosten der
virologe hier aus berlin gesagt hat
kürzlich in diesem interview mit den
tagesthemen
das heißt nach ostern ist es warm dann
wird das geschehen abgemildert sein aber
es wird auch nicht komplett stoppen wie
im letzten jahr ist meine voraussage
jetzt mal also ich würde schätzen das
schaukelt sich zum sommer wieder hoch
wir haben kein infektions freien sommer
aber es ist eben ein sommer wenn wir da
zum beispiel in innenräumen maske tragen
dann kann man das geschehen so
moderieren dass es nicht außer kontrolle
kommt und dann kommt der winter da muss
man auch wieder härter durchgreifen
also der nächste corona winter steht uns
bevor
ist das ist leider zu befürchten daher
werbe ich ja oder kennen ich werbe nicht
ich kämpfe für die allgemein
nebenpflicht stehen uns folgendes vor
folgendes szenario mir kommen
einigermaßen gut über den sommer dann
kommt der winter also die herbst läuft
einigermaßen aber dann käme
beispielsweise eine neue variante oder
es geht einfach nur meckern man stelle
sich vor die fasern gehen wieder hoch so
wie jetzt 300 tausend fälle am tag 300
tote aber dann ist eben nicht wie jetzt
das gute wetter vor uns sondern der
winter steht vor uns dann müssten wir
natürlich maßnahmen ergreifen weil also
stellen sich wie werden die werden wir
jetzt vor dem winter stunden bei den
jetzigen fallzahlen haben jetzt schon
die überlastung der krankenhäuser ich
habe über die hotspots gesprochen gerade
dann müssten wir reagieren und dann
wären wir wieder ändern und das würde
auch die wirtschaft massiv
herunterdrücken weil viele also viele
also sein mal
wissenschaftler
wirtschaftswissenschaftler oder auch
also
konjunkturforscher aber auch viele
unternehmer denken das ist im herbst ist
das vorbei aber wenn wir dann im herbst
die wirtschaft nimmt er sowieso im
moment einen stoß wegen der ukrainer
krise wegen des krieges wegen des
vorspann krieg ist aber wenn wir dann
plötzlich die nachricht verbreiten
müssen wir müssen wieder bereiche
zurückfahren wir müssen wir dann würde
auch die die wirtschaft dass eine
rezession werden nicht ausgeschlossen
somit selbst aus ökonomischer sicht ist
es einfach
dass wir dem flüge nicht schließen und
daher appelliere ich auch an die union
auch hier an friedrich merz selbst wenn
man von der epidemiologischen gefahr
nicht so sehr beeindruckt ist was ich
schade finde weil es sind hunderte
menschen die jeden tag sterben aber
selbst wenn er sagt dass es für mich
jetzt so nicht so maßgeblich dann ist
aus wirtschaftlicher sicht ist es
einfach absolut notwendig dass wir jetzt
handeln darüber streiten wir gleich auch
über die impfpflicht weitermachen eine
ganz kurze pause sind gleich zurück mit
dem minister dem gesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach hierbei bild
[Musik]
zurück bei bild die richtigen fragen an
den bundesgesundheitsminister an karl
lauterbach und wir reden natürlich auch
mit ihnen wieder über zahlen jetzt haben
sie schon in dieser sendung auch immer
wieder diese 300.000 genannt die zahl an
neuinfektionen die sie in wahrheit ja
aber auch nicht kennen sie selbst
sprechen von einer gewaltig hohen
dunkelziffer aktuell das heißt
eigentlich ist das doch eine gute
nachricht wenn die dunkelziffer so hoch
ist dann ist ja die sterblichkeit die
hospitalisierung noch viel geringer
aktuell durch omikron als wir sowieso
schon auf dem zettel stehen nein sie
wird ja nicht geringer das sind ja
absolute zahlen die mich interessieren
wenn 300 menschen am tag sterben ist es
unerheblich also wie viele sich
infiziert haben diese handelt leute sind
ja tot wir haben ja gerade mit ihnen
über hospitalisierungen und über
ansteckung usw gesprochen aber dann
lassen sie uns bei der zahl der toten
bleiben die hat eine rolle gespielt auch
in der pressekonferenz mit lothar wieler
dem rk ii schauen wir noch mal ganz kurz
rein
wir beklagen die 300 tote pro tag und in
der letzten woche ohne insgesamt wieder
mehr als 1000 mitmenschen als todesfälle
registriert in verbindung mit cupid 19
er hat sich verrechnet sie oder her
wieder ich hatte ja auf den tag mich
bezogen also wir haben ja in den
wochentagen haben wir mehr tote und am
wochenende wären weniger gezählt wir
haben ja am wochenende wegen der
erfassung der todesfälle viel weniger
sind sie manchmal nur 25 30 tote weil
eben nicht voll erfasst wird die toten
werden dann an den tagen danach
registriert sodass also an den
wochentagen hörer todeszahlen sind
außerdem wochen ist sie haben sich jetzt
bewussten wochentag rausgesucht an dem
es hoch ist weil der eindruck entsteht
an derselben pressekonferenz sie sagen
300 am tag und sagen dann in der fußnote
unten da ich meinte jetzt den heutigen
tag morgen und übermorgen wird die
rechnung niedriger ist das haben sie ja
nicht dazu gesagt ich hatte ja sagte in
derselben konferenz das sind deutlich
weniger als das ist so ist es keineswegs
gemeint gewesen wenn ich mich auf die
also wenn ich sage bis zu 300 tote
sterben am tag oder gestern sind bis
gestern sind 300 tote zu beklagen
gewesen
dann also ist das also relevant die die
zahl der toten pro woche habe ich dann
davon habe ich ja nicht gesprochen und
er habe aber setzt sich relativ leicht
ausrechnen dass hatte in dem moment
haben auch viele zuschauer gemacht wie
zum beispiel heiko brühl der genau das
gesehen hat und der uns auch noch mal
darauf aufmerksam gemacht hat und er
sagt zu einer zu der aussage von herrn
lauterbach das täglich 250 bis 300
menschen an corona versterben auf welche
quellen statistiken bezieht sich laut
aber kennen sie die zahlen nicht oder
interpretieren sie die bewusst falsch
ich interpretiere keine zahlen bewusst
falsch das mache ich ganz grundsätzlich
nicht und die zahlen werden ja vom
robert-koch-institut
täglich veröffentlicht das heißt es sind
die gleichen zahlen sind die gleichen
zahlen der punkt ist er also am
wochenende werden manchmal die
todesfälle nicht komplett registriert
aber
die
täglichen todesfälle werden ja
aufgelistet und somit hat man am
wochenende weniger todesfälle und in der
woche hat mir war der komplette rest so
wichtig ist und das war ihm ja auch in
der argumentation wichtig auch um noch
mal auf die gefährlichkeit von corona
abzuheben um das noch einmal deutlich zu
machen wie viel corona tote zählen wir
müssen wir aktuell zählen in deutschland
pro woche etwa die also die zahlen
dieser woche habe ich aktuell nicht aber
wir zählen alle toten und listen die
gesamtzahl der toten tagesaktuell auf
der homepage des robert koch instituts
und sind in den letzten wochen
sind tausende tote dazugekommen wir
liegen jetzt bei fast 130 tausend toten
und ich finde muss ich ganz offen sagen
wir niemanden zu nahe treten aber ich
finde also diese art und weise zu
versuchen
die glaubwürdigkeit des
robert-koch-instituts noch meine
glaubwürdigkeit infrage zu stellen nur
weil man deswegen am wochenende komplett
gezählt wird dann ein ich dich hinein
und das haben wir nicht getan und das
ist auch nicht die absicht von unseren
zuschauer gewesen sondern er war
tatsächlich daran interessiert das zeigt
ja diese frage wie viele sind nun unter
der enns redlich gefragt wenn sie
nebeneinander sitzen herr lauterbach in
der pressekonferenz und sie sagen es
sind 300 am tag und der chef des rk ii
sa es sind 2.100 schon das ist nicht
ganz richtig sprach von 250 bis 300 am
tag und ich glaube an den tagen also
davor waren es jedes mal eher 300 als
200 das sind die tägliche sich so sind
die täglichen todesfälle das am
wochenende nicht komplett also
gezählt wird
das ändert doch nichts daran dass auch
am wochenende die menschen sterben das
ändert überhaupt nichts daran es ist ein
drama das nach wie vor nicht gezählt
wird ja dass die zahlen an solchen tagen
so große schwankungen erleben ja das ist
ja aber auch gar nicht der punkt gewesen
sondern wie gesagt sie saßen
nebeneinander unterschiedlicher angaben
gemacht und der zuschauer sitzt davor
und sagt was ist das jetzt und warum
sagte er es so und er ist so ja gut das
war also die ich hätte
auf die täglichen todesfälle das ist das
was relevant ist wenn jetzt mal nach
wegen in der woche jeden tag in der
woche wo die wo die erhebung
vollständiger ist am wochenende ist
schwieriger weil dann zum teil nicht
komplett aber wenn ich jetzt fünf tage
hintereinander habe wo also 200 bis 300
tote haben das muss doch als nachricht
genügen das kapiert doch dani das
verstehen sie doch dann ich hab's doch
vorher verstanden aber ich habe es nicht
verstanden weil sie nebeneinander saßen
und sich gegen seine nach widersprochen
wir haben uns diese irritation ist bei
ganz vielen jahren standen an lassen wir
jetzt möglicherweise auflösen alles gute
naja ich bin doch ich reagiere da ein
bisschen angefasst weil also
immer wieder also wird also diese
diskussion die wir haben am wochenende
werde nicht komplett erfasst also da
sind es dann wirklich weit weniger tut
als wenn dann wenige leute am wochenende
ich dann würde ja oder dass man nicht
mal ansatzweise teil meiner gut aber ich
höre dass immer wieder auch auf den
sozialen medien bekomme ich ja diese
fragen auch oder diese idee also sind
die leute mit kurve an kurve gestorben
und so weiter und fordert sind alles
prächtig war sie ja umso korrekter zu
sein gerade in solchen pressekonferenzen
die die menschen tatsächlich wahrnehmen
als hochamt ja das wäre dann hier meine
pflicht gewesen hätte ich sagen sollen
am tag sterben 250 bis 300 tote ich muss
aber darauf hinweist und am wochenende
wird nicht komplett gezählt
möglicherweise hat sehr viele ja in dem
moment auch falsch gemacht der eine
hochrechnung über die woche
die heraus geblasen hatte sich mit ihren
angaben ja aber dabei so ist das design
stimmt habe ich nur die idee wäre dann
ja gewesen diese woche sterben uns jeden
tag 200 bis 300 tote aber am wochenende
haben wir keine vollständige erhebung
ich bin aber es kann daher genug ist
noch so lang ja aber nur das was da muss
man auch ein mindestmaß an also
vertrauen haben wenn der
bundesgesundheitsminister sich da also
hinstellt und sagt also wir uns sterben
250 bis 300 tote am tag das muss man
dann auch es muss sich wirken lassen
überlegt was können wir machen um das
hätte jeder getan wenn ich im selben
moment fast im selben moment als app des
lkw plötzlich andere zahlen ein paar wir
ziehen kurzen strich drunter und
sprechen über die impfpflicht herr
bundesgesundheitsminister
kanzler scholz war hier als er noch
nicht ganz kanzler war und hat diese
impfpflicht angekündigt das war im
dezember hat angekündigt dass er sich
dafür stark machen werde dass das im
bundestag entschieden werde jetzt haben
wir die uhr schon ein bisschen weiter
gedreht mittlerweile sind ende märz und
wir haben die impfpflicht noch nicht
nicht gerade ein zeichen von
führungsstärke also zunächst hat er ja
was ich richtig fangen sofort sehr
schnell das zu einem thema gemacht wo er
auch dafür steht dafür bin ich dankbar
weil in vielen anderen europäischen
ländern wird die impfpflicht gar nicht
debattiert da stellt sich kein
regierungschef dahin und sagt wir
brauchen den sieg weil es ja auch in der
bevölkerung umstritten olaf scholz hat
das getan dafür bin ich sehr dankbar und
ich bin absolut der gleichen meinung wie
er wir brauchen die impfpflicht dass es
dann länger gedauert hat dass es dem
verfahren geschuldet wir haben es dann
haben uns dann gemeinsam entschieden
dass es ein verfahren ist wo der
deutsche bundestag die allgemeine
impfpflicht anbringt und nicht die
regierung das war die entscheidung da
kann man unterschiedliche machen sagen
ob das klug ist oder nicht ich halte das
für eine richtige entscheidung ist eine
wichtige ethische entscheidung einmal
apps nicht wollte und da das ist eine
unterstellung ist es auf jeden fall so
die die fdp auch wenn die fdp das
blockieren wollte könnte sie es auch im
parlament das heißt die fdp ich brauche
die ich brauche die abgeordneten der fdp
auch also wenn ich das also durchsetzen
will im bundestag die fdp es dann ja
nicht weg die fdp muss mit stimmen und
die fdp hat ja sogar durch den
abgeordneten ullmann an sehr guten
antrag sogar gemacht und daher alles gut
ich glaube dass zum schluss einfach
zählt ich blicke immer nach vorn es ist
jetzt zeit vergangen ich blicke immer
nach vorne ich bin also hier mal im
infektionsschutzgesetz aber so mehr war
rechtlich nicht möglich ich arbeite mit
dem was möglich ist ich blicke immer
nach vorn und hier ist bei der
impfpflicht ist es so wir haben es nicht
schneller hinbekommen jetzt steht es
strittig ob es überhaupt kommt ich
kämpfe dafür ich blicke immer noch
frauen ich versuche immer das beste
herauszuholen mit den gegebenen
möglichkeiten
jetzt sagen sie den menschen aktuell das
nicht zwingend noch ein nächster booster
eine vierte impfung sie werben
einerseits dafür dass die fürther
impfung nötig ist auf der anderen seite
sagen sie für die impfpflicht aber ist
das wiederum nicht nötig warum ist das
so warum gibt es diesen unterschied also
zunächst die dritte impfung schützt
schon den allergrößten teil derer die
drei mal geimpft sind vor schweren
verlauf und furcht dass solche
verstanden somit also es reicht um die
allgemeine impfpflicht durchzusetzen das
ist auch die position der meisten
wissenschaftler auch die maßen also
mitglieder der fachgesellschaft für
immunologie der deutschen gesellschaft
für immunologie trägt diese position ist
es wissenschaftlich unstrittig dass man
mit drei impfungen gut durchkommt jetzt
gibt es allerdings also bei älteren
immer noch dann nach drei impfungen eine
kleine gruppe die trotz der dritten
impfung schwer erkrankt oder einige
sterben auch und wenn ich jetzt dort
einen ratschlag geben weil die vierte
impfung ja keine nennenswerten
nebenwirkungen hat aber trotzdem noch
mal einen schutz gibt dann empfehle ich
die vierte impfung das tue ich auch
gerne hier in der sendung bei ihnen es
ist in den letzten tagen eine studie
veröffentlicht worden die ich für sehr
wichtig halte in diesem zusammenhang in
israel ist die vierte impfung ja für die
über 60 jährigen empfohlen vier monate
nach der dritten und da hat sich gezeigt
dass im vergleich zur dritten impfung
bei den über 60 jährigen aus nicht bald
ein junger bei den über 60-jährigen das
sterberisiko noch einmal ganz deutlich
sehen das macht einen großen unterschied
und ich weiß dass wir derzeit auch viele
60 bis 69 jährige auf den
intensivstationen haben die um ihr leben
ringen mit omikron obwohl sie
vollständig geimpft und gebucht hat sind
daher also ist der schutz der drei
impfungen sehr gut wurde für die
allgemeine impfpflicht komplett
ausreichend aber derjenige der sich
besonders schützen will und sich selbst
einen gefallen tun will dem würde ich
empfehlen die vierte impfung zu nehmen
dieses jahr ab 70 empfohlen aber auf der
grundlage dieser neuen und sehr
wichtigen studie recht nicht damit dass
wir das auch noch mal anpassen werden
und das dann ab 60 empfehlen ich habe
den leiter der stiko herrn professor
mertens gebeten dass wir uns zu prüfen
für das bundesgesundheitsministerium die
prüfung beginnt wir sind in kontakt aber
die studienlage ist aus meiner sicht
eindeutig die über 60-jährigen gewinnen
deutlich an schutz gerade in der
mikrowelle jetzt indem sie eine vierte
impfung nehmen der schutz beginnt schon
eine woche nach der impfung sollte die
impfpflicht scheitern aus ihrer sicht
scheitern treten sie zurück nein das
nicht also ich sags mal so wenn die
impfpflicht scheitern sollte wer eine
vorsichtige konsequenter corona politik
umso wichtiger und ich glaube für diese
stehen zu können ich zeige ihnen eine
frage unserer zuschauerinnen katja mücke
sie fragt uns fragt sie vor allen dingen
wann werden den studien zu den
nebenwirkungen der korona maßnahmen bei
kindern veröffentlicht als
gesundheitsminister tragen sie besonders
verantwortung natürlich für die kinder
auch dafür gibt es so etwas gibt es so
etwas in ihrem ministerium was ganz
gezielt im moment vorangetrieben wird
wir suchen ja die studien die es also zu
den nebenwirkungen der maßnahmen so gibt
auch bei kindern also die suchen wir
systematisch heraus und werten alles aus
was es dazu gibt auch im expertenrat wir
haben ja sehr renommierte also
wissenschaftler kinder also erste
professorin für kinder und
jugendheilkunde professor deutsch und
professor boerne im expertenrat und die
besetzung ist also experten hat habe ich
ja wesentlich mitbestimmt da war es mir
sehr wichtig dass da auch kinder
spezialisten dabei sind die haben die
aufgabe und haben sich dazu auch schon
also immer experten hat geäußert solche
dinge systematisch zu untersuchen dass
die studien die es gibt die werden wir
aus das muss nicht verlangt werden
sondern es wird gemacht das machen die
experten die für das
gesundheitsministerium da im
arbeitsleben sie nicht zurück und sagen
na ja das was wir nicht hin kram ich bin
es nicht ich muss wirklich also hier
also davon nämlich abstand das sind
unterstellungen das machen wir nicht sie
ist einfach nicht frage hält nicht frage
genau darauf ziele ich habe das
thematisieren sie sich für dieses thema
auch werden sie das mit voller natürlich
voran selbstverständlich also ich habe
ihnen jetzt nicht unterstellt dass sie
mir das vorwerfen das war nicht der bus
dann würdest du angekommen ist dann bin
ich das zu entschuldigen das wollte ich
damit ich sein aber es gibt leute im
netz die das unterstellen die also sagen
die schauen nur nach dem koma so
maßnahme veröffentlicht was ihm passt
und passen und das machen wir nicht das
ist der expertenrat ist vollkommen frei
und wir haben den expertenrat gebeten
ausdrücklich gebeten jedoch mit der
situation von kindern
auseinanderzusetzen und das ist auch
geschehen somit da wird natürlich nichts
nichts verheimlicht haben sie auch alles
getan um über impfnebenwirkungen um die
fälle zu ja diese zu veröffentlichen
darüber zu informieren können sie sagen
unser zuschauern denn diese fragen
kommen das haben sie gerade schon
angedeutet tatsächlicher massenhaft ja
was ist mit all diesen fällen warum
reden sie nicht darüber über diese
impfschäden haben sie alles getan um
darüber zu informieren das tun wir doch
also das paul ehrlich institut ist in
europa besonders renommiert was also die
vorbereitung von zulassung von
arzneimitteln und auch von dem stoffen
angeht und
darüber hinaus also auch was die
erfassung und veröffentlichung von
nebenwirkungen geht da ist kann man
sagen das paul-ehrlich-institut schon
also einer größe auch im europäischen
vergleich das war nicht immer so aber es
ist jetzt so wo andere hinschauen das
paul-ehrlich-institut ist bekannt dafür
in europa sehr also gründlich zu
arbeiten und da hat auch der jetzige
also vorsitzende cicek professor jay
khan wesentlichen anteil hat das
wirklich sauber gemacht und also daher
veröffentlichen wir die nebenwirkungen
also
regelmäßig komplett alles was also
geprüft wird auch die qualitätskontrolle
oder also nebenwirkung überprüfung ist
also gewährleistet wird genau
beschrieben und somit wird dann nichts
verheimlicht ich erinnere mich dass er
vor kurzem mal eine krankenkasse der
meinung war da wären nebenwirkungen die
da nicht erfasst werden konnten so das
ist das so soll das kann vorgetragen
werden es war einfach so nach einer
überprüfung das war alles nicht
stichhaltig kann man ist an der der
vorsitzende der kasse musste
zurücktreten nur uns so etwas ist
richtig das muss immer wieder aber wir
sind da wirklich sauber und gehen
präzise vor haben den bogen schlagen von
beginn der sendung über diesen
schrecklichen krieg die folgen die auch
sie sozusagen behandeln müssen in ihrem
bundesgesundheitsministerium natürlich
haben sie zu kämpfen mit der aktuellen
flüchtlings lage mit hunderttausenden
die kommen wahrscheinlich werden ist
über eine million menschen seien
deutlich mehr die nach deutschland auch
kommen viele von ihnen sind ungeimpft
oder können das zumindest nicht
nachweisen völlig klar in den
kriegswirren und möglicherweise ohnehin
völlig klar macht ihnen das sorgen macht
mir sorgen dass genau und das ist auch
ein thema unserer
gesundheitsministerkonferenz morgen wir
werden darüber reden wie wir also die
gesundheitliche versorgung der menschen
die aus der ukraine zu uns geflohen sind
darstellen können dazu zählen auch die
impfungen aber werden wir auch prüfen
welche rolle die impfzentren für die
impfung der geflüchteten menschen
leisten können das ist ein wichtiges
thema also ein schnell programm zum
beispiel wäre wäre denkbar wäre möglich
daran arbeiten wir wird darüber
nachgedacht
hier geht es ja nicht nur um die korona
impfung sondern wir sind riesige im flug
und auch für andere impfungen und da
versuchen wir einen weg zu finden wie
wir möglichst unbürokratisch und schnell
diese wichtigen impflücken schließen
können in der tat wir reden nicht nur
über corona impfungen auch ganz
wesentlich über masernimpfungen
natürlich das ist zugangsvoraussetzung
in der kita in der schule das stellt im
moment ganz viele die dort in der
leitung sind beispielsweise auch vorgang
schwierige moralische entscheidungen man
möchte diese menschen gerne in die kita
gruppe aufnehmen gerne in die schule
aufnehmen aber man darf es einfach nicht
weil der masern nachweis hier das fehlt
wir arbeiten sie damit um also wir
arbeiten dran ich gehe mit den dingen
immer gleich um also wenn sich bei mir
ein problem
meldet
sich sofort an die arbeit und das haben
wir hier auch getan und hier arbeiten
wir also mit den gesundheitsministern
der länder nach einem vorschlag sind
schon da tja es mal sagen dass ich aber
ich bleibe dann dann muss noch genauer
werden dass ich schon vor etwa zwei
wochen habe ich also in meinem
ministerium eine arbeitsgruppe gegründet
unter leitung von frau dr teilen gar
nicht mehr lang gar nicht wahrsagen nach
ich will nur für die kita leitung oder
der schulleiter einmal wissen wie soll
der jetzt handelt sollte er erst mal
sagen kommt gar nicht infrage ich nehme
die kinder erstmal nicht auf weil die
haben keinen master nachweis das ist ja
die die rechtliche grundlage genau so
eben wie bei 1 infektionsschutzgesetz
natürlich kann also hier nicht gegen das
recht verstoßen wäre es recht sagt dem
wir haben eine maß an nachweispflicht
und daher also ist das problem hatte ich
aber ich will nur den einen punkt noch
sagen weil mir das wichtig ist also ich
versuche einfach wenn ein problem da ist
er sofort an lösungen zu gehen und hier
haben wir schon also eine arbeitsgruppe
unter leitung von also frau doktor
talstadt die war früher die leiterin des
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
deutschlandweit ich habe mich
eingestellt eine ganz tolle frau und
mitarbeiterin und die arbeitet in mit
ihrem team bei mir im haus an einer
lösung dieses problems das geht nicht
wenn es geht nicht also sofort aber wir
sind dann schon ziemlich weit und wir
werden darüber morgen mit den
gesundheitsministern der länder sprechen
verstanden stand jetzt ist aber kinder
aus der ukraine die kein masern nachweis
impfnachweis haben die bleiben draußen
lassen sie werden nicht eine deutsche
schule eine deutsche kita ob wir da eine
also pragmatische lösung finden das wird
sich zeigen das wird sich zeigen ob
damit eine ausnahmeregelung arbeiten
können wir müssen mal schauen dazu
gehört unter anderem dass wir uns ein
bild davon machen also wie weit
verbreitet sind eigentlich maß und jetzt
bei den kindern gekommen aber ich glaube
wir können das problem einfach anders
wir müssen die kinder aber auch die
erwachsenen hier sehr schnell nachdem
sind und daran arbeiten wir mit
hochdruck gesagt die arbeitsgruppe ist
schon anderthalb wochen in aber das
nicht ganz so simpel weil es ist so dass
also die sie müssen überlegen wo wert
geben dort wo die leute ankommen dort wo
sie dann hin kommen usw man weiß ja gar
ländle da sind die länder zuständig ich
habe ja hier in also im bahnhof habe ich
die
chance habe ich das ankommt zentrum
besucht hat mir da ein bild gemacht mit
übersetzern mittel menschen gesprochen
habe versucht mir einen überblick
verschaffen was ob dort überhaupt wissen
ob sie selbst oder ihre kinder geimpft
sind das war zum teil nicht der fall die
wussten gar nicht ob sie geben sind
somit da kommen viele probleme zusammen
aber
probleme sind für die saison da um
gelöst zu werden da bin ich rüber gehend
ist natürlich die kita leiterin der
schulleiter damit alleine da steht jetzt
natürlich hat er das recht vor augen
aber er steht auch von der gewaltigen
moralischen frage und muss das
vorübergehend selbst für sich lösen
genauso aber er kann aber er kann daher
die kita-leiterin kann daher aber
dankbar dafür sein dass bund und länder
schon schnellstmöglich von samana
problem zu lösen ja kurzer strich
drunter unter die sendung mit dem
eigenen geldbeutel sozusagen herr
lauterbach immer wieder die frage auch
nach den krankenkassenbeiträgen
einerseits das große entlastungspaket
von ihrer regierung der ampel regierung
mit geschnürt hunderte euro für jeden
auf der anderen seite ja muss versteuert
werden und so weiter wird schon ein
bisschen was abgeknapst aber jetzt
wollen sich auch noch was haben
krankenkassenbeiträge wieder rauf wie
kommen sie darauf warum muss das sein
steigen gar nicht unmittelbar sondern
hier geht es darum was passieren muss
damit die krankenkasse ein solides jahr
2023 haben und wir müssen aber jetzt
schon mit der planung beginnen wir haben
also eine erstklassige
gesundheitsversorgung in der groner
krise anbieten können mit dafür
verantwortlich ist diese versorgung mit
da für verantwortlich dass wir diese
gute sterblichkeit und auch also sagen
wir im vergleich zu anderen ländern
geringe quote von sehr schweren
erkrankungen hinbekommen haben das hat
geld gekostet
daher haben die krankenkassen viel
ausgegeben sie haben gleichzeitig
einnahmenverluste gehabt was wird ja
über die arbeitnehmer und
arbeitgeberbeiträge bezahlt und wir
haben viele dinge schließen müssen von
daher sind weniger einkommen sind
weniger einnahmen zusammengekommen daher
haben die krankenkassen ist ein defizit
das ist aber kein defizit durch
verschwendung von geld das eigentlich in
jedem ressort sozusagen das
entlastungspaket wieder das ist dann ein
im vergleich zum entlastungspaket sind
die beiträge die wir zum schluss
zusätzlich nehmen müssen minimal oder
das entlastungspaket ist viel größer als
die summe über die wir hier reden also
im vergleich zum entlastungspaket sind
sind wir in einer ganz anderen lage
zumindest mit irgendwelchen anstieg
etwas kann ich möchte kann und möchte
ich hier nicht sagen das paket muss
endgültig fertig sein und da wir über
einen effizienzreserven heranziehen die
krankenkassen haben zum glück noch
rücklagen dann werden wir also den
beitragssatz ein bisschen erhöhen es
wurde auch mehr steuergeld geben das
wird auch ganz viele schultern verteilen
die mal sagen sie minimal es wird ein
kleiner anstieg seien genau danke an den
bundesgesundheitsminister hierbei bild
danke an karl lauterbach da gehen wir
sind zurück am nächsten sonntag die
richtigen fragen
[Musik]